Prosper à cause de la GRC.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Montréal-Nord, c'est 85 000
résidents, un des quartiers
les plus peuplés au Canada, mais
aussi un des plus multiculturels
et défavorisés.
Alors que s'amorce
cette campagne municipale,
les électeurs ont de nombreuses
demandes.
- La propreté; il y a des rues
où c'est pas vraiment propre,
à Montréal-Nord, là.
- Des services publics
plus accessibles. Vous savez,
Montréal-Nord, on parle depuis
15 ans d'un centre sportif.
- Des logements pour le monde
qui attend des logements.
- Mais un enjeu revient plus
souvent dans les conversations
et inquiète particulièrement.
- Avec les armes à feu, beaucoup
plus de contrôle, beaucoup plus
de sécurité. En fait, c'est
juste à ça que je m'attends.
OUARI BENAOIDA, propriétaire
Sapori Veri
- C'est devenu le Chicago
de l'époque avec Mme Plante!
Les policiers, ils travaillent
jour et nuit peut-être, mais
ils sont pas arrivés à faire
quelque chose, ils ont besoin
peut-être de renforts.
- La flambée de violence
qui frappe Montréal n'épargne
pas l'arrondissement, épicentre
du phénomène des gangs de rues.
En deux ans, une bonne vingtaine
de fusillades ont eu lieu dans
Montréal-Nord. Les candidats
pour la mairie s'en font parler.
- Je me demandais c'est quoi
que vous auriez pu amener pour
justement... pas nécessairement
éliminer, mais peut-être
juste comme enlever un peu
cette réputation-là?
- Christine Black, la mairesse
sortante de l'arrondissement,
se représente dans l'équipe de
Denis Coderre. Comme résidente,
elle s'inquiète elle aussi,
mais défend son bilan.
CHRISTINE BLACK, candidate
Montréal-Nord, Ensemble Montréal
- On n'a pas eu d'incidents
avec des armes à feu répertoriés
depuis le début du mois
de juillet. Donc si ça va mieux
à Montréal-Nord depuis quelque
temps, c'est justement parce
qu'on a mis des énergies pour
faire en sorte que le service
de police puisse continuer
son travail et avoir
des stratégies différentes.
- Aux électeurs qu'elle
rencontre, elle demande de voter
pour son équipe expérimentée,
qui a investi pour améliorer
les espaces publics,
dans les parcs notamment.
- Oui, ça prend des
investissements dans le service
de police, mais ça en prend
également au niveau
des organismes communautaires,
au niveau aussi des aménagements
urbains dans le quartier.
- Christine Black a l'avantage
de faire campagne dans l'ancien
arrondissement de son chef.
Denis Coderre a habité Montréal-
Nord la majeure partie de sa vie
et a été député fédéral de la
circonscription pendant 16 ans.
- J'habite toujours André-Jobin.
- André-Jobin.
- Le quartier de Denis Coderre.
- Ah, bien oui, bien oui!
- C'est mon ami, Denis Coderre,
c'est mon ami!
- Oui, bien là, il faut aller
voter!
- Bien oui, bien oui!
- Non, moi, je trouve que
ça va bien, c'est sûr qu'il y a
recrudescence de la violence,
là, mais...
- Will Prosper est le principal
adversaire de Christine Black
et il se présente pour
l'équipe de Valérie Plante.
Documentariste et militant
antiraciste, il a grandi dans
Montréal-Nord, où il a lancé
un organisme pour venir en aide
aux jeunes. C'est une des clés,
selon lui, pour prévenir
la violence.
WILL PROSPER, candidat, mairie
Montréal-Nord, Projet Montréal
- Moi, j'en ai vu des jeunes,
j'ai travaillé avec des jeunes
qui étaient sur un chemin
beaucoup plus à risque, puis
on a réussi à les récupérer,
puis les transformer, puis
maintenant, c'est des leaders
dans notre communauté.
Est-ce que vous connaissez
Will Prosper?
- (enfants): Oui, oui, oui!
- Nous, on croit qu'on doit
traiter les enjeux profonds
de cette communauté-là. Donc
on parle des enjeux de pauvreté,
des enjeux de logements, des
enjeux d'activités parascolaires
et quand on investit là-dedans,
on réduit justement les jeunes
qui sont à risque.
Il faut juste investir
suffisamment auprès des jeunes.
- J'ai décidé de voter
pour vous parce que j'ai dit :
Enfin, quelqu'un qui connaît
Montréal-Nord!
- Alors qu'il travaillait
pour la GRC il y a 22 ans,
Will Prosper a été soupçonné
d'avoir divulgué
des renseignements policiers
à un ancien ami impliqué
dans une affaire de meurtre.
La GRC l'aurait ensuite forcé
à démissionner. L'histoire
a plombé son début de campagne,
mais la page est tournée,
dit-il.
- Je pense que ma feuille
de route au cours des dernières
années est très claire :
on a fait énormément avec
très peu de moyens.
- On croit beaucoup
à la deuxième chance.
- Le milieu socio-communautaire
de Montréal-Nord semble
lui avoir pardonné, mais
sans prendre parti dans
cette course à la mairie.
BRUNILDA REYES, dg
Les fourchettes de l'espoir
- M. Prosper, il est impliqué,
Mme Black, elle est impliquée;
et les deux connaissent
la problématique et connaissent
aussi des solutions.
OUSSEYNOU NDIAYE, dg
Un itinéraire pour tous
- Je vois aussi son engagement
auprès de cette communauté.
Donc les deux, à mon avis,
j'ai de la difficulté à
se placer d'autant plus que
j'ai réussi... je travaille
avec les deux, je connais
leur engagement envers
cette jeunesse.
- Cette lutte à suivre, ici,
est vue comme une chance de
mieux faire connaître Montréal-
Nord; ses besoins, mais aussi
ses atouts.
- Il y a un paquet d'actions
positives qui se produisent
dans cette communauté-là
qu'on ne voit jamais, hein?
Montréal-Nord a mauvaise presse
malheureusement très souvent.
- C'est une mixité qui fait
toute cette richesse de
Montréal-Nord et tout le monde
cohabite, tout le monde
s'apprécie et cette partie-là,
on a à la découvrir, je pense,
et à la faire valoir
beaucoup plus.
- Christine Black et
Will Prosper ont un grand défi
à relever au cours du prochain
mois : convaincre la population
d'aller voter. Aux municipales
de 2017, seulement un électeur
sur trois l'avait fait
dans Montréal-Nord.